when we first moved here people thought
we were crazy there's a reason why
there's not a lot of farms here in
Minnesota
it's not much soil the climate is harsh
we knew the land could produce we
figured we'd figure it out
this great big story was made possible
by horizon organic I'm Lisa
Boz this is my husband David Abbas and
we are off-grid organic farmers in
Finland Minnesota
Finland is a small community along the
North Shore Lake Superior we've been
farming this land for last thirty plus
years people have said you can't farm in
Finland this soil was both infertile and
challenging that one you can't get a
shovel into the ground because it's full
with rocks but it didn't matter
everything it just felt right the soil
industrial farming treats it as a medium
to grow crops you insert the nutrients
and the crop grows but organic farming
it focuses on making that soil its own
living organism you have healthy soil
you end up with healthy plants and so we
focused on making sure we were feeding
the soil not just the plants this is all
good soil start to get a little denser
here through time through compost to
cover crops and care we're able to see
results and now the fertility is so much
greater than it's ever been
[Music]
our growing season can be as short as 33
days in the spring we grow lots of
greens we have lettuce spinach kale
we have radishes and beets we need water
we need food we need energy we've tried
to figure out how do we do all of those
everything we run is from solar and wind
power a water is pumped from the earth
we use a compost toilet and of course
you know what home said would be
complete without a flock of free-range
chickens
most of what we grow is distributed to
customers through a CSA which is
community supported agriculture it's a
way for small farmers to get dependable
sales of their products we sell about 50
shares which can feed a couple hundred
people for many years we've been
involved in the social fabric in the
community so we installed solar at the
fire station and then the community
center so that was all part of kind of
mainstreaming renewable energy into our
community sharing what we've learned by
living this way will hopefully make the
world better
you